- - Il se retient, mais il est
fufurieux. Robert Lafrenière
ététait le grand patron de l'UP.
IlIl est maintenant désigné
cocomme l'un des suspects
d'd'une enquête criminelle
dudu Bureau des enquêtes
inindépendantes sur les fuites
d'd'informations dans les média.
ROROBERT LAFRENIÈRE,
exex-commissaire, UPAC
- - C'est complètement faux,
lele fait de mentionner dans
unune théorie que j'ai orchestr,
dodonné ou, peu importe le verb,
leles fuites pour m'améliorer au
niniveau de mon renouvellement,
popour avoir un corps de police,
c'c'est complètement faux.
- - Cette théorie, c'est le coer
dudu projet Serment, du BEI, qui
dudure depuis trois ans et demi.
- - Mme Denis, je vais vous
lele redire, là : j'ai jamais
enenvoyé de documents ou remis
dedes documents à quiconque.
- - Après avoir rencontré
13130 témoins, le BEI allègue
quque Robert Lafrenière serait
lala source de six fuites, et qe
seses proches collaborateurs
seseraient impliqués dans
1313 fuites. Mais les documents
sosont imprécis sur qui aurait
lalaissé fuir quoi.
- - D'avoir imaginé ce qu'ils
didisent, c'est... il faut être
fofort.
- - Alors, vous dites qu'ils ont
imimaginé des choses?
- - Oui, et solidement.
- - Ces allégations étaient
jujusqu'ici inconnues du grand
pupublic. Mais elles ont été
dédéterminantes dans
l'l'acquittement de Nathalie
NoNormandeau et Marc-Yvan Côté.
PaParce que l'enquête pour
ididentifier les auteurs
dedes fuites entraînait
dedes délais déraisonnables.
- - Alors, c'est mon sentiment.
IlIls ont... partis avec
lala théorie que j'orchestrais
totout ça. Puis là, ils ont troé
dedes choses autour. Ils ont mis
dedes choses autour... puis
ilils ne sont plus capables
dede s'en sortir.
- - Donc, une vision tunnel?
- - Oui, en plein ça.
- - Précisément ce qu'on...
- - Ce qu'on nous reproche,
cece qu'on nous reproche.
- - Vous pensez que c'est
exexactement la même histoire qi
sese répète, mais à l'inverse?
- - Oui.
- - Tout un retournement de
sisituation. Le juge Perreault
adadhère à la théorie du BEI et
coconclut que l'enquête qui a mé
àà l'arrestation de Guy Ouellete
enen 2017 a été faussement
ororientée par Robert Lafrenière
etet ses adjoints, et que
lele projet A de l'UPAC était
cacarrément bidon.
VoVous êtes convaincu que
cecette enquête-là était bonne?
- - Absolument.
- - Encore aujourd'hui, même si
totout le monde l'a conspuée?
- - Robert Lafrenière dit que
leles enquêteurs du projet Sermt
n'n'ont toujours pas demandé
sasa version des faits.
LeLe BEI confirme que l'enquête
esest toujours en cours et
esespère soumettre un dossier
auau directeur des enquêtes
crcriminelles et pénales
enen décembre.
I Ici Marie-Maude Denis,
R Radio-Canada, Montréal.